Yeah. And today's the 25th of September. All right. Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcasts for
Monday. They say podcast podcasts for Monday,
September 25th, 2017. What's going on? How are Ya?
What's up? I am back from a Toronto, Canada, and every once in a while,
every once in a long while I have a,
I have a guest and I always get good guests. And this is, no,
today is no exception.
We have the great Philippe [inaudible] on here who has a a welcome,
first of all welcome. They had me was so food, there you go.
Fully based bars in front of what's up, fool podcasts and uh,
let's get all the hype out of the way. At first we got a,
you have a new HBO special? Yes.
A new HBO with Bash on September 30th at 10 September 30th at 10 on HBO.
That's where the HBO specials are called. Translate this. So, uh,
let's get into it. Tell me about that. What's it like to shoot a, uh,
hour long special for HBO?
Um, it was, it was good. Um, I shot in myself. Um, I, I,
um, I got the money together, I saved up some money and my wife and I, we,
um, we chose San Jose Improv and we got cloud shires.
And, um, it was all DIY, you know,
so you did it yourself and an HBO liked it so much they bought it. Oh,
so when you were doing it, you weren't thinking like, Holy Shit,
I'm doing an fields
that I don't know where it's going to go. Like, oh, go to Netflix somewhere.
Even Amazon. Yeah.
No, but that's, I think that's a, uh, that's a great way to Donna,
fuck is nobody giving you a shot. I don't know.
You know why you're not white like me. Um, I gotta be honest,
before we, I did this, you know,
I was looking up like videos and all that type of stuff to make sure I got
something to talk about. So it doesn't become this, like,
my biggest fear with these interviews is it's just gonna become this horrific
staring contest. Cause I'm such a huge fan of what you do.
And I had never seen the, um, the Irish,
a few in Irish affair was hosting the show. Uh,
this isn't happening when you told that whole story about,
uh, being in the gang and fight in the guy biting his era and shit,
it's just like, like I was listening to that, that story. It was like,
this is like at least three different Tarantino movies and then you ended in and
just such a nice place. Um, I don't want to force you to tell this story again,
but if you could just read it.
Mine, um, I would start by where did you grow? I grew up in, um, Boyle heights,
California. You know, Los Angeles, but east la, but it's called Boyle heights.
You know, east La is like further east,
east Los Angeles. You know, it's by almost close to Monterey Park,
but Boyle heights in the neighborhood right after the fire away. Is that,
to put it in white perspective, how far away is that from the staple center?
Ooh, if I were to walk,
it'll take me like an hour and hour drive. Probably 50 minutes with him.
Two minutes. Okay, cool. A 30 minute bus ride. Okay. 30 minute bus ride.
So you grew up, uh, what you, what,
what decade you were a child of what you Katie's you're the eighties okay.
[inaudible] eighties so that was the real deal. Yeah. I grew up in,
my neighborhood was in the housing projects [inaudible] Pico Gardens and there
were like three separate in housing projects. There was at least so village,
Pico,
Aliso and then Pico Gardens from first street to like sixth street and there was
like Saint Mary's with like a shit load of gangs, like maybe 11.
How did you, now when you're not in a gang and you're a young kid,
how do you negotiate? Like I got to get from my house,
I got to go pick up my, my fuck, I got to go do my laundry,
I got to go to school. How do you negotiate? Is it a no. A gangs.
24 seven
Oh yeah man, the 25th that neighborhood they were 24 seven p I,
I always thought they came out around five like anybody with like just live in
the regular lifestyle goes to bed and then they just kind of give up this,
the area there. Yeah.
And those gangs, they come on at five.
They're like the gangs that are still living in a gentrified neighborhood. Okay.
They don't come on a daytime. They might call the cops on them. Oh yeah man.
But most gangs, you know from Echo Park, they come on at night, man.
Robbing people. Really? Yeah. They come on at night. Those guys were,
where were the gentrification? Those gangs are still around,
but they come on at night and they gang bang or different areas, you know.
But they're still gang banging. It'll hot yet.
How old were you the first time you got mugged?
I got mugged on the first time when I was like 18 years old. My friend,
I'm cocoa. That's pretty good man. Yeah.
I got called 18 downtown crossing when I was like in eighth grade.
That I was like, I was out selling crack on my first day like that where they,
one hour I got robbed,
somebody put a knife behind my back and other knife in my like in front of me
and they took all my, my crack away
to call you crack away. So then, then what do you have to do?
Oh,
I have to go back to the guy who gave it to me or a friend of mine who I grew up
with, you know,
he passed away already cause they used to call them cocoa and we grew up
together. Him and I were, um, from second grade to adults.
I needed money at the time I got somebody pregnant and I didn't know how to make
money. So I asked him for a job in the criminal business,
can I, you know, hey man, I had no money. How does that go down?
You probably how avoid it. It's like I don't want to sell drugs, but I,
I kind of have to now I got a kid calming, so help me.
So he gave me like $100 of, of crack, you know,
a hundred to just bring me back a hundred. They didn't give you more to sell.
So as soon as I got out, they didn't know who I was in that neighborhood.
They just came around me and he took all my stuff.
They didn't hurt me or anything.
I was begging for my can I keep my id and they gave my id. I liked it.
How scared were you? I was scared, man.
I thought they were going to kill me right there. I was starting.
I felt like I was young. I was really scared, but I was calm, you know?
I wasn't like, uh, right. Just take your mind. Just take you, leave me alone.
You know, just walked out of I take it.
I didn't fight him or nothing cause I knew they would've killed me or stab me or
worse.
So went back to my friend Coco and I told them what happened and I thought,
you know, he was going to be okay man. You know it's alright. You know,
that's your first hands. It happens. No Man,
it man that night and it like it took with it.
He gave me the crack and I go on midnight,
I go rather our one 30 at two 30 in the morning, I'm back at his house. What,
who robbed you? Cause so what happened? He gave me a gun,
he gave me some sense of rice.
He got himself a pistol and he and he put a blue handkerchief on [inaudible]
head and up and he put a black beanie on and we both were looking for those
guys.
And you must've been praying to God like I don't want to murder somebody to
first. Oh hell yeah. Mouth pray. Please don't find those guys. Wow.
Cause I thought I was like I would've probably would done anything.
He would have told me, oh the vulnerable. I was weak. Right. You know I have no,
I didn't know what to do.
So we went together and we saw one guy that saw what happened but he didn't do
anything and, and then like he kinda like hit him real hard and who did it? Man,
where are the ad then I said, man, it wasn't here man. It wasn't him.
So it wasn't him. Wait, how did that, I see you all. I basic,
I remember that guy standing there watching me get robbed.
So now this poor pastor gets dragged into it. He gets dragged into any,
he got like he got a gun slap, you know by my friend.
He's my friend name and ask him a question and he just hit him in the face hard
man and like started beating,
I mean the year and I just say wild man. He was looking at me like, come on man,
please tell him they wouldn't meet. So you wait until after the pistol slap.
Oh Hey, I met them at to tell you this. It wasn't him.
So we got nothing happened to him and we went back and later on those guys who
actually did it, walked back and gave it back or everything,
get back to crack to that guy and everything was cool because of what he has
said. Sorry, we didn't know that they were afraid of that guy. Yes.
I really don't know. Batman went with you. Yeah, we should st nicknames. Yeah.
So then after that, then they knew that you were with him,
so then people stopped fucking with you. People stopped messing with me. Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
This is what kills me about you is you have like a thousand of those stories and
you're the most relaxed, laid back guy ever.
Like where did it all go? Because Dude, I look at me,
I sound like I lived your life and you sound like you lived my life.
Like you sound like you grew up in a nice little culdesac area and played street
hockey and I'm all fucking wound up. How did you do that? Well,
I have a mom. I have parents.
I had my mom and dad and most of my crazy friends and the project,
you know the crazier ones, they didn't have a mom and dad. Right.
They had nobody telling him you better come home early or there was nobody
telling them those kids to come home. The lights go on in the streets.
So they had no really nobody telling them what to do, how to live. Right.
No discipline. I had my mom and dad, mom and worked and my mom stood up,
Amman worked at a elementary school at the doors,
be home from selling crack when the streetlights came on. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
You had that. But I've always got family foundation,
but I don't get that. I just now you're talking, you've got a home life,
but you're telling you you're doing all this other shit. I know the kid,
you know when I was like 13, 12, 14 years old, I wasn't crazy. Oh,
I see you crazy. After high school. That's the one I'm pregnant.
I just didn't know what to do, but I was always like a little hustler man.
My Mom was saw a barn and I will collect the money for her.
[inaudible] you know, so I learned how to collect money for people,
at least from my mom was always telling her, um, herbal life, Avon,
she was always studying something.
Can we live by the warehouses in downtown la where the factories are at,
where other trucks will come in and pick up stuff on the trains and take them to
like stores.
So when Momma knew where like we used to go to this one factory and we,
we used to um, put a bunch of that synthetic cotton, the plastic one,
they would throw it away and my mom and I will put it in bags,
like hefty bags and then we go to another place where they will throw these
raggedy old sheets.
And then my mom was so those regular old sheets with the cotton and then we'll
walk, we'll go the door to Dell, door to door in a housing project.
Selling pillows.
Okay.
So you guys were a real green family man. You were there, you were there.
Recycling [inaudible] we saw we fired a trash and we've slowly, like,
we've so pillows I used to when I was like 14 I used to walk to downtown to do
with pallets. Would you build a little house and then sell that? No Man,
that's too much work. I want to, we want fast money. Oh, okay. Cash.
Although with a bunch of factories where I live, you know,
I felt like I felt like Henry Hill from Goodfellas. Right.
Because they were always stealing stuff from the airport and we were always
taking stuff from the factories. I wasn't stealing from these factories.
My friends where I was taking stuff on the trash, like, um,
though there was a watermelon factory and they will throw away rotten
watermelons and I will get the watermelons and clear them in a watermelon.
Like they, they make watermen like [inaudible] should grow them.
Know that they were getting from the farmer, I guess. And they, right.
They would hold them there. They have pallets full of watermelon from could.
There's like a grocery area of downtown la where every grocer gets all this
other stuff. Flowers, stereos, you know, you name it bananas.
I know where everything is. That suits the cheap suits.
I know where everything's at.
So we'll get the hang out and just go to the dumpsters.
And whenever they threw out, you would then go sell. Yeah,
I will cut the watermelon and a half and then go sell it to the Mexicans.
They laborers, everybody that working in the factories, much of immigrants.
Right. And that was the half a water metaphor.
A dollar $2 five I'll just cut the writing piece off.
You know what I mean? Oh, it wasn't awhile. Nobody looking.
I will send my little home girl, this girl,
the little less well should have lesbian now,
but we didn't know she was a lesbian now. She was like a tomboy.
I was sending her in there with my brother and then when there was like when
they were, nobody was looking,
they would throw good watermen in the trash can too.
So we had a mixture of good and bad water minus.
How long did you stay in that whole world of selling crack and all of that and
all those fights and biting the guy's ear off and all that shit before you
became a comedian, like how long, how long was that period of your life?
That was my period of from 18 years old to like 21 and a half.
21 and a half because at 21 it's when I was like messing up already man.
I was like, I'm out smoking a lot of PCP.
That was like my drug of choice for the time being. And Man,
I used to get all grades, PCP,
PCP and like I think it's an elephant tranquilizer.
That's what people tell me.
I always say that grown a PCP angel does and all that and that Angel Angel does.
It's like coming crystallized PCP. You could put it in a cigarette butt PCP.
In my neighborhood, we were at the PCP Capitol of the, of Los Angeles,
like in my neighborhood, they sold gallons of it. People had to,
they wouldn't have on sparklers water full of PCP,
so everybody had PCP. Wait a minute, you how did, did you ingest it? You smoke?
No, you, they're like a, I'm giving away secrets here.
I'll tell you. I'm asking because everybody tries to act like, Oh,
you understand [inaudible] I don't know any of that stuff.
You will get a new port, cigarette out, Korea, menthol, cigarette,
a new port and then you put your arm and you dip it instead of a little jar.
Like, I'm just a tip.
And that's a $5 tip as a $5 dip it dip it again at 10 you dip a whole one is 20
you know, you, you soak in this $30 it's by dip. You know,
now I get it. That's like when I drank booze, there's like the 10 year old shit.
You're the way up to 25 then you get into the cognacs and that can be like,
I dunno,
like I don't wines and shit could be like a century year old and something.
So there's one night I was smoking PC pint.
Just cause I'm stupid as hell when it comes to it. So what is it?
What stat highlight is man, it's like you're the incredible hoke.
If somebody attacks you,
oh this is a shit when like five cops shop and they gotta see that.
I've marked that. You see that child Bronson movie? That's where three,
when one white boy, like the surfer he's been at,
he's fighting all the police officers. He's on PCP. Okay, I got to rewatch that.
Yeah, man. PCB you think you have,
I'm like incredible hoke strength. But you just have like Mo,
you don't feel pain, but while people are hitting you, man,
you could just keep attacking forever. You know what I mean? Right.
And then the next morning you wake up and you feel like you played 12 years in
the NFL. Yeah, man. All right.
So the first time you smoked PCP and that shit hits you,
it's like literally like you're turning into like a superhero. Yeah, man.
Well, the one time, what did you do? Did you try to bend something? Nah,
that's what I want to talk cops now. No, that's what I would've done.
I would've tried to pull something off the fucking wall.
I better go to the Arona. Well that when I would let walking around, they'll,
I'll be coming to be known as Batman. You know, he's crazy. We'll chalk for him.
Why did they call you? Why did they call you Batman? Cause I'm,
I love Batman and I used to wear my, those um, superhero on the ruse.
[inaudible] and 18. Yeah, mass duet. Where the Batman shirts still afraid.
So I wore it and I didn't know where to get a Batman shirt anywhere else.
It was the underoos factory right down the street. Yeah.
It took it out of the dumps to the bad projects. Yeah. That's amazing.
All right, so you're doing all that. I'm watching. Um,
I'm at the drive in theater with my friends smoking PCP watching terminator to
asking why I saying I'd fight that guy. Yeah man.
And I'm thinking about the guy that's been bullying me for the last two weeks.
So I go, no, wait, if you smoke that, say a guy views,
I fuck I shouldn't do this cause I'm like doing a commercial here for the drug.
Say this, somebody bullying you and you, you can't beat that guy. Right.
If you were to smoke some pee PCP, it definitely would give you the belief,
but can it overcome how slow you are and your inability to slip a punch and you
just walked through is shit. Yeah man, you're throwing punches. Cause, um,
when I, when that got into a fight with these guys,
I w they told me I was doing things that I remember doing that they told me that
took my belt off and I was whipping them all over though we keep alluding to the
story. You gotta tell this story, right? So you're Batman,
you got on your under roofs, you smoked PCP at the driving.
He saw the terminator two when I left the Terminator two movie,
I come back into a project and I see this guy that he looked like an old dude,
man, he's like 30 years old. He just came out of prison. He don't know who I am.
He's like calling me bad names and I'm pushing me and pushing me and I don't
want to fight him pushing me. They finally, I socked him in the face,
but I kind of missed that. He hit me right in the eye and he hit me hard.
And My, I got black right away. He punched me in a face. I started bleeding.
They started choking me. So when he started choking me, that's when I like,
I went crazy. I went crazy, man. I lifted him up,
dropped him better. I bit his deer. Well, first of all, I've been here.
I've been here. I've never let the whole Cogan ever tell your brother.
Let me ask you this. When you paid his ear off, were you underneath?
Are you on top of him? I was like underneath him. He was choking me.
And you just, all of a sudden that PCP, I paid it off, man.
I never thought my skin is solos.
Easy to bite off and spin crochet out ice? No, not even,
man. I spit it out and I started punching him and then my friends told me that,
um, wait, what did he do? Oh Man. I took the hits like a soldier.
So when you bend his ear off, this guy seal scout, he's,
he's screaming like a little girl. Okay. Do you think pain?
So he's Kinda screaming like a guy got his ear bit off.
He's agreeing with that point. I think you still a man, if you,
if you go up a few octaves when you're missing a fucking deer,
but I don't know why. I believe Europe mainland. No, I get, I had no choice.
You know, he was choking me. Sounded like that was the move.
No one was helping me. He wasn't, didn't seem like he was going to be stopping.
All right.
See you beat you then you took your belt off and you or my friends told me that
I took my belt off an authority whipping him.
Like he was like chasing him with a belt, whipping them. Like, like he was like,
oh, runaway property or something. And how many people are witnessing this?
It's wild 15 people. But they're all assuring me on showing him on,
nobody's helping the enemy hits that word. Get like nowadays,
if they do that would be, that might be like,
it would be epic PCP guy, epic belt guy.
They'd be something like that. Or would have been a rap song.
Autotune Batman wherever. Yeah. So wait a minute. So when you,
so you don't remember doing that. So there was like, oh fuck,
this guy's going to kill me. Then you start to bite his ear off. You're like,
wow, ears come off really easily.
Then you sort of blackout and then like where you just sort of came to with like
blood all over. You going like, uh, the night of a hotdog or stuff together?
The next day I wake, the next day I'm walking, going around, it's like 10,
seven in the morning, eight in the morning. I don't know man. I'm looking at,
my body is full of blood, my pants, my face. You know my,
I have a black guy and my shirt is full of blood. I have no idea what happened.
I have no idea what happened. You probably thought it was your blood.
That's why I didn't know that. Whoa man. I was like checking Stephen.
I got shot or stabbed by somebody they didn't know.
Then my friends told me what happened and the guy was in the,
he went to the hospital for like a broken ribs my senior year.
Missing ear, you know where he's just putting your sporing on in that house.
And they went to, he were laying in bed and they asked him if I'm,
do you want to press charges? You know,
cause everybody know there was witnesses. Everybody knew who did it and he said,
no, we're going to handle it the right way. And I was like, wow,
I didn't even know know this until later on like a week later he goes, yeah man,
I think there was like a green light on you right now in the mean like green
light. What do you mean green light? Yeah man, shoot to kill. They see you.
What the fuck. So that's the first time you ever heard that. So now what?
Now what do you do besides not go outside? Do they know where you live?
They know where I live, but I don't know the, he's still in a hospital though,
but everything's calm, you know, but he's doing a hospital.
But I can feel tension from people who are,
who I thought were my friend or one time who I, who I grew up with, you know?
You know they were turning on me like, cause I was never in their gang.
I was in another gang. When you watched the wire, do you like fall asleep?
Is it like boring to you because it was the wire you don't need to you it.
So I'm like, it sounds like a in award-winning series to me.
I'm more like bloody and blood out. So wait a minute. So now,
now there's a green light on you. Yeah. And Hey,
at some point you got to go outside to get food because you're hungry. Yeah.
So when you have a green light on you in, in East La,
what's a good time to go out to? If you got to go hit,
hit the Mayfair market or whatever. What's it called?
Man that out to go to Dubai. When you know,
when you have a green light and in from anybody, you know,
whether it comes from prison or ever come from just the neighborhood,
it's just relieve man, move somewhere safe. Like Modesto.
What's a more serious greenlight?
If it came from prison or from the neighborhood or the,
if it come from prison and you're a dead man, man.
I mean there's nowhere to go there. Nowhere to go, man. And, um,
I read about these things, you know, on top of it, on books,
there's no way coming back from that.
But there was like only like a green light from his neighborhood, you know,
like go to the mall, no matter like the grove, pick a really white mall.
And you know what all those thoughts came to my mind at that time. Like, man,
I wish I would like the fresh prince of Bel Air. He said,
I wish that rich white guy didn't take a rich white guy or a wish fucker Mexican
guy. Oh, no way. They weren't wearing that show. That was different strokes.
That was different strokes. But to drumming, they switched it up. They're like,
it's different strokes. Except the marathon bought into right now. Yeah,
that's what they, oh, they always do that shit.
So my mom called out Father Greg Boyle.
He's like this priest that I grew up with in the neighborhood.
He's from the homeboy industries here in la. That's a thing.
Yeah, he helps. He helps them. Gang members. That's a cool name.
Father Greg Boyle. He'd like a priest from my neighborhood and um,
he's always helped the neighborhood.
Like he would go out of his way to help people. He will like,
if you like driving and then you like,
he will pick up kids that were drunk off the streets and take him home.
He did that a couple of times for me in a good way. In a good way. Yeah.
Like if you're a gang member in the wrong neighborhood and then you know,
you're pretty much,
someone's going to kill you in that neighborhood for the great boy will tell
you, get in a van. I took you back home as a, as,
as a gang member.
How do you end up in the wrong neighborhood other than a woman, a man on PCP,
they're goddamn pieces. There's no, there's no heroin in your neighborhood.
So now you gotta go buy heroin somewhere else. You know,
there's no crack in the neighborhood. You know,
there's a dry spell somewhere and you got to get high,
so you're going to go to another neighborhood and buy it. Oh God. Oh,
you have a aunt. So how do they know you're in a different gang?
You don't go over there wearing your whole, Your York, your colors, right.
Most of the hardcore gang members, they wear the colors, man. They,
they're not gonna start wearing it colors your boy, they're not on the cover.
They're 24, seven. But other than one, I wouldn't want even one of those guys.
I was nothing like that.
I was just the guy who was just hanging around with these kids.
And then one day I get jumped into a gang and I'm getting
into so much trouble, but I don't know, ideas to get beaten into a gang.
Just in case I ever fucked my life up. And I go to prison, you know,
when I go to prison, my only hope is I gotta join the area and Nazi guys,
I can listen to them bullshit and pretend I believe it just to save myself.
How long is that beat though?
Um, well in, in, in the streets it would be like,
I guess whatever number the gang is. So with 18th Street,
you gonna get beat up for 18 seconds. That's it. Yeah. Or, but I mean,
how many guys are all of them? Oh Jesus. Okay. Fuck. Okay.
Strike thing. That's it from the record there. Cause when I got jumped in,
I was just hanging out, man.
Like I was just hanging out and if somebody said I'm a man,
you want to get jumped in. And I wasn't gonna say no. If I say no, I'm a punk,
I'm gonna get jumped in. I'm gonna get judged for being a punk. So I said,
fuck it, let's do it. And then I punched the guy next to me for no reason. Well,
because I want to prove that I'm, I'm, I'm tough. So the guy next to him,
I just knocked him out with one punch man. And then I hit like,
he wasn't even looking. I said, let's do this. And then like, I hit him. Right.
You know, you gotta be ready. Big Dog. You gotta Look
God holy this at Warren Sapp moment. Keep your head on a swivel. Look man,
I bet he get the other guy's shit later. Like, Hey,
next time you're going to jump somebody yet, can you not say what?
I'm sitting right next to him. You knew he was a lefty. What the fuck? Yeah,
you get beat up, man. And I got Joe by everybody that one in.
And did you get more than one end? Did you get one? I got two in one.
Him and another guy.
But then after that I felt like I'm Nike cortex all over my face.
So you're just laying on the ground and you just go one Mississippi two but just
waiting for this rain of, of footlocker to stop coming down on you.
Yeah, man. I was like, I thought I was never going to stop, man.
So what do you do? I would just, they're funny. They start over. I hit it off,
hit enough. Then everybody hugging me,
the same people that were beating my brains up were hugging me and kissing me.
You, I love you. You're my boy. You're my family now. And they're like, wow.
So then you come home. Okay. And then you just sit in there,
all right with fucking sneaker marks all over you. And you're going like, okay,
now I guess I'm in a gang. Jesus Christ. Okay,
so then what happens? Um, I thought it,
what happened was I thought of hanging around white people who talk about white
privilege going through, what the fuck is that? This is what it is.
Totally. Yes.
You can sit there selling lemonade at the end of your driveway and then
accidentally did I just join a gang? There was a, there's a green light on you.
You was selling lemonade at the end of the wrong driveway.
You're in the wrong neighborhood. It was dumb. But you know,
like there was two white boys in my neighborhood that were gangs was one the red
headed kid from children, the corn.
Exactly. He was, he was, he said, well one guy, he was a blood, actually,
he was from east La. Slow man, they call them. Okay. There was a,
there was actually two white boys, mad offensive by the way, but continued.
There was two white boys in the hood, man. And they were both gangbangers.
And one thing I bought white boy Cholos like when you see a white boy join a
gang and when you see a white guy like someone like you and you're hanging
around with nothing but Mexicans, they're white.
White guys are the most craziest gangsters.
When they were in a Mexican gang and they do stuff that I'm Mexican man will
never think of like, I remember this one white guy, snow man, he was a blood.
He said, man, let's go do a home invasion. And I,
and everybody was asking him where he goes, my mom house.
Oh you wanted a home game. All right.
And he wanted them, he wanted the eyebrow,
all the homeys to rob his house because he wanted his mom and dad to get rob.
Why? Cause I don't know,
they're probably saying stop hanging out with all those Mexicans.
His idea and I was like, Damn.
So they probably behave that way cause they felt no matter what they,
they had to constantly prove constantly man.
Because technically they could just get a haircut or whatever,
put away the flannel and just slip, slip away, man.
Slip away down at the grove civil way,
become a social worker and that'll be it. So how long were you in this gang for?
And did you ever get beaten out?
No, I wasn't in his gang too. I'm, when I'm father gray boat went and bit,
that guy's deer off. I went to Rehab,
my father Greg Boyle took me to Rehab and um, I, I disappeared for,
I'm still gone. I never went back.
Oh, he never went back or, yeah. When you get beaten out of a gang, how,
how long has that beat though?
As long as they want to. Um, I know what we had,
I had a guy on a podcast named Fabian who was in a,
in a gang and he talks about, he got beat up, beat out,
he got jumped out and he said that when you got jumped, they just last longer.
But, um,
his uncle is doing the gang [inaudible] expression course.
It's doing the gang. So his uncle oversaw him getting jumped out,
so he didn't get hurt that bad. Uh, I don't have an uncle.
I probably would've got killed if I got jumped out with them when I was 20. But
the white version of that is our dad's the judge.
So we don't go to jail over whatever the fuck we just did.
Your version is you got an uncle that oversees being jumped out.
I got to tell you dude, I'm learning all kinds of stuff.
Like I wonder why I don't know my case.
Somebody's just walking by somebody's recorder.
It's always feels weird to have to like re hype something.
So your special on HBO that you shot yourself learning all of your,
do it yourself stuff from fucking going around in those warehouses,
making pillows out of, out of nothing. Um, you ended up shooting this at uh,
the, uh, the Improv in San Jose,
which is one of my favorite classes at a great club.
Cause you feel like you're doing a theater. You know, even it's a club.
It's tremendous.
And a, you shot it there.
It's going to be on HBO September 30th at 10 o'clock called translate this.
Now are you, um, I know you're a great joke writer, but you, uh,
I saw an Irish a fears you told that and he told the amazing story that you,
you touched on today. Um,
is your s a stand up style in this more joke telling more storytelling or both?
Well, you know what my, my comedy special is, it's more about, um,
it's more about how I got to this country with my parents and um,
being a single father and being a cheater.
But yeah, man, I cheat a lot. I got caught cheating,
cheating all the time. I'm bad. I can't help it.
I love women.
I talk about getting caught cheating cause I was caught cheating, you know, um,
burden. Both girls showed up to my house. Oh God. You know what I mean?
Leah in man, it was crazy. And he asked me were you going to save yourself? How?
Checkmate, how long was that beat down that long in 18 seconds.
It was crazy. They showed up in the same car with G. Oh,
they fray talked to each other. Yeah, man. Well now they film it and shit.
And then you go in there and then you're going to do like an apology and all
that shit though. First 48. Yeah. Wow. Okay.
So you're going to do it. I can't wait to see this, but I'm not sure. I can't.
I really honestly do
stand up comedian. I cannot wait to see this. Thank you.
One of the most interesting dudes I've been. How are you so fucking happy.
Go lucky.
I don't get it. I Dunno. Imagine love life. You know, I'm never,
I'm never going to go back to that type of lifestyle that I had in my twenties.
And I'm, I just love living life man.
And I'm not going to say that I'm perfect because I'm, I did fall off the,
I was where after I went to Rehab, I was sober for 11 years.
Like I didn't trust no drugs. I didn't trust no alcohol, no beer, nothing.
But, um, along the way you know that the more that they stand up comedy,
the more you know, I did it. Not going nowhere.
I went back to smoking crack. She went right back to crack.
She never really were a booze guy. Huh?
Now it's probably an unboosted domain gun. He say do,
it's like Ralphie may retweeted my tweet the other night and I'm,
I don't understand what he meant at first because I was in Houston and he
retweeted, um, what y'all follow spoons bro?
And then like, what the hell is roughly where you're talking about him spoons?
Then I say, Oh shit, Burt,
I got so coked out in Houston, Texas.
I, I, they known for that day. I couldn't do no more coke.
My nose was bleeding, so I wanted to rock it up and smoking and crack instead.
You know, cause I want to see you just like,
I'm just going to snort a couple of lines. Yeah. But did you,
did you anticipate like you were like, fuck this, when I go to Houston,
I'm gonna Party?
Or was it a spontaneous thing and all of a sudden you just said, fuck it.
Oh Man, yes, I was over there. I'll working the laptop in Houston.
Shout out to Pete,
booking me Pete and from the laptop. Um, I've got,
I've got, I started party, man. I, uh,
I started partying and I couldn't find no powder, no coke.
So I'm hope you don't mind me Italian did, but I, I it with Joel Diaz, I say,
ain't your deal, you know anybody over here,
you caught him in at six in the morning and cause soccer.
What the fuck is wrong with you? Probably my six in the morning. You fucked
[inaudible] saga. Ah,
I also have Greg, Joey. I know somebody.
Huh?
So I knew he knew somebody. I know that he, I,
I'm gonna go talk to this comedian.
So I spoke to his comedian and then I'm this little Mexican food showed up all
week, take care of me. I give them a free tickets every day. I think you,
and um, I, I don't know what happened, man,
but I did too much coke and I felt like I can't do no more code through my nose,
you know, so they're gonna go bad. I want to smoke crack now.
You know what I mean? I don't want to stay a long burgers.
Now due to reoccurring story with you is,
I don't know what happened last time. He didn't know what happened.
You were whipping somebody with a belt.
Now you don't know what happened is like a fucking hole in your nose.
Jesus do we, how long ago was this? This wasn't them. 2006. All right, so you,
okay. Thousand seven, 2006. So you broke your record, you've gone,
you've gone to 11, five. Yeah, I called up um,
room service to the one who smoked crack and I call it a company.
You would call it a room service. And I say room service. I'm going to need,
I'm a big spoon and a baking soda brought over right now.
And they did not bring that to the room. Oh they blinded man.
They did to guy that brought in the guy on the front there.
He knew me cause I'm made friends with him already know from previous times and
he brought it and it was like a big spoon and he brought it arm and hammer
baking soda. And the guy with him, he just with, with him to laugh at me,
I guess he goes, Hey, I guess I couldn't believe it.
You know this guy you'd order baking soda and spoon. No Way. Let's go see.
So the bolt open the door, they give it to me. They both laugh.
But yeah man, I wanted to smoke crack. Okay,
so and then, and then how long were you off the wagon for?
From when? Okay, so you're sober for 11 years.
You go to Houston, you order a spoon and some baking soda. Now you,
you snort coke, now you're smoking. I got you partied that weekend.
Did you just come back and go, what the fuck was that?
And were you able to or did you have to go rehab? No Man,
I continue to party man. From that moment on. And the girl I with with man,
she ended up being a hermaphrodite. But that was another story for another time,
you know? But yeah, sure.
The hermaphrodite she had was born with a peanut and a vagina. Right.
So like how long was she your girlfriend before you figured that out?
Well, we were party with three and gentlemen. Yes, that's what I was,
I wasn't a gentlemen.
I didn't want to touch her or nothing because she broke free coke, man,
I can be that guy. So I just kissed her a couple of times,
but then by the third night, you know,
we were off for three nights to rate her and I,
but when I finally found out I was like, whoa man. Yeah,
that's a big skin tag you got there.
So it was that enough. So it was at enough to get you sober again. No Man,
I didn't get sober again to two, you know the nine that stop sign. All right,
so now we're still going. I didn't get sober till 2009. Oh fuck.
I was off and on.
And you are already doing.
So during those periods you were still doing stand up and you will,
yeah, I was doing standup.
I would even know I even got to go to Montreal comedy festival in 2005 and um,
I was bad. I did the young comedian show and I did well.
I guess I did well. I got a little,
I little print on the Hollywood reporter. I got an agent.
Uta, actually they didn't have any idea you were high. No Man, I was young.
I was smoking crack in Montreal too. I hooked it up. I mean,
I found crack in Montreal. It's funny,
I saw a Mexican guy in Montreal and a new,
he spoke Spanish and I told him, man, could you tell him?
I just could tell man he had the boots. You know,
he had that look like w w I need a job. You know,
I didn't even know what that means. It's hilarious. He got the boots, you know,
he had that look like I just got here. Cross country.
So he spoke Spanish. He spoke Spanish,
no English, but he was know, he knows how to speak French now.
But with a Mexican, you know, Mexican accent, you know,
doing all the romantic languages. So he
[inaudible] and de indicates back a romance language. Yeah, man. Crack.
Well, all right dude, you are,
I could talk to you for like fucking 10 hours and you just don't run out.
It's amazing, man. I don't know. Thank God you're still here. I'm sober now,
man. I know, but all this stuff you've done, you know,
like realistically you probably could have died in 80% of the stories. You just,
man, I'm glad I'm alive. Yeah, I am too, man.
Cause I think you're a fucking amazing comedian and person.
I'm psyched that you're on all the all things comedy podcast network with the
whatsup fool podcast. I'm, I wish you nothing but the best with your, uh, your,
your stand up special HBO, Saturday, September 30th set your dvrs,
whatever the kids do now, your cord cutters,
whatever you do to fucking see this thing and uh,
more success to you and stay out of Houston are, will. Boom.
All right. Thanks Philippe.
Thanks Bill Burr. Billy Burke. All right. That was
Philippe spires and Malik fucking guy's amazing. Please check out a special,
I just said all that shit.
I gotta do my reads here and then I'm gonna talk a little NFL football.
Maybe answer a couple of questions. Fill out the rest of this hour here. A.
All right, our first, oh Jesus, look who's back. It's old zip.
Rick wrote up. Um, talk about the challenge of finding,
I'm not doing that with ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to 100% 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to your job
better than anyone else. That is why that is why. That's why zip
back corridor is different. Unlike any other sites,
ZipRecruiter doesn't depend on candidates finding you would find them. In fact,
80% of employees who post jobs on zip
get a quality candidate through the site within one day.
No more juggling emails.
You don't have time for that shit or calls to your office. Simply screen rate,
manage candidates all in one place at ZipRecruiter's. Easy to use dashboard.
Find out today why zip
[inaudible] has been used by businesses of all sizes to find the most quality
job candidates with immediate results. And right now,
my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free. That's right. Free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/burr that's
ziprecruiter.com/burg one more time for free. Go to zip.
Okay.
[inaudible]
croda.com/ [inaudible] um, all right.
MVMT also known as movement.
The company that started what was started by two broke college kids that wanted
to wear stylish watches but couldn't afford them.
They had no money and somehow they started a watch company. Uh,
so they started their own watch company. Um, how is this like how you started?
Well, I didn't have any money and I then I started a comedy club.
I built my Kuranda fuck it. What I got,
I got to come up with like a metaphor here. Movement watches start at just $95.
At a department store.
You're looking at four to 500 bucks and that's why people steal no more
shoplifting or boosting whatever your people call it. Movement figured out
that by selling online,
they were able to cut out the middleman and retail markup,
providing the best possible experience.
Over 1 million watches sold in over 160 countries.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and free returns by going to movement
watches.com. That's M v M t.com/burr.
This watch has a really clean design. Seriously,
I've been getting compliments and not just on my eyes.
They're talking about the watch. Now is the time to step up your watch game.
Go to M v M t.com/burr. Join the movement and lastly,
but not Lezley,
stamps.com the cornerstone of this podcast advertisement.
Avoid the hassle man of the post office and mail everything from postcards to
envelope to packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in just minutes online with no equipment to lease and
no longterm commitments. Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for lettuce or packages at your convenience.
24 seven a key word slash, descriptors. I guess I'm supposed to say this.
It's convenient. It's easy, it's reliable, it's flexible. All right,
just like you side piece there. Sorry. I use stamps.com because,
uh Oh, I always, whenever I sell posters at the end of my show,
when I'm wanting to go out there and say, shake sweaty hands, you know,
and I need to send out my posters.
I use stamps.com and I'm a more on if I can figure it out. So can you,
and right now you two could enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without
longterm commitments. Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbyrdthatstamps.com enter borough one more
time. Hey, stamps.com never go to the post office again.
All right, that's it. Okay. Stomach is growling here.
I'm still on my fucking diet. Oh, Billy died.
Some fucking asshole sent me a tweet going like,
you're obsessed with your fucking weight. You look fine. Get help. It's like,
dude, that's why I look fine. You fucking moron. You don't give a shit.
You potato skins, Eaton fat.
Fuck these guys with your thick fucking torsos. You know what I mean?
Making that noise. When you reach back to get the seatbelt,
trying to pull it around you running out of material.
I don't want to be that guy. You know what I mean?
That guy who gets killed by his airbag because his fat face is too close to the,
the miniature explosion. Um, anyways,
all things comedy festival by the way, podcast festival, October 26th,
27th, 28th, 29th in Phoenix. Ticket links@billbird.com.
By the way,
I am going to do my first ever live Monday morning podcast there at this stand
up live, um, comedy club. I'm going to do it live.
I'll do it live and I'm going to do it just how I do it my fucking house.
All right. I thought about getting the guest and I was like, fuck that.
That's not the CIM of what it is that I do. So I'm just gonna do it.
I Dunno what to lay down on the stage.
I don't know what the fuck I'm going to do,
but I'm going to do it the exact way I do.
So if you ever wanted to see this shit live, this absolute train wreck,
if you wanted to see what it looked like in real time, come on down to, uh,
the standup live comedy club in Phoenix, Arizona. October 28th. I will be there.
I don't know when tickets go on sale. They on, I guess they're on sales now.
They're on ticket links. We're at bill bird.com. There you go. All right. Um,
anyways, let's talk some NFL football. Wetback
did you guys enjoy it? Did your team, when
my team won the New England patriots,
who everybody said was going to go undefeated and then we lost to the Kansas
city chiefs and then everybody said, oh, wait a minute. Wait a minute.
I think Tom Brady is old now. I think he's washed up.
I think the Kansas City chiefs,
they're gonna win their first super bowl since 1970.
That's what everybody said,
because the Kansas City chiefs beat the New England patriots in September.
Now all of a sudden they can see January. How fucking crazy is that?
How many fucking times? How many times are you going to watch? The giants go,
Oh, in two and oh and three and just start writing them off. You saw the points,
they scored high. You think they're not going to come back and beat Philly?
They're not gonna come back and be Dallas later on this fucking year.
When they all get on the same page, they will protect any lie much better.
According to the 30 seconds of highlights that I saw.
I'm sticking by my prediction. New England patriots,
New York giant Superbowl rematch. All right?
Until the Kansas City chiefs, who I actually like until we Andy Reed, who?
I'm not saying he's fat until those fuckers do something in January.
All right.
I think all you need to sit down a little bit and fucking relax with all your
shit talk and how many fucking guys have you seen throw for 500 yards in the
regular season and get bounced out and the first round of the playoffs,
how many times did you see a fucking Guy Zigzag and all over the field?
You can't tackle them and come play off time.
He sitting on a fucking exercise bike wearing a tinted windshield crossed his
eyes. Huh?
The incredible lack of fucking respect that you gave our little quarterback that
could Tom Brady. How dare you.
How dare you write off the New England patriots after one fucking week. Huh?
It's all wishful thinking.
We're coming again and we're going to take your hearts out and we're going to
pull them out of your chest.
We're going to show him to you and then we're going to under inflate them on or
a way to another fucking, actually, we never got caught doing that.
They just suggested that we did it and they got laughed out of court. Um,
and then do, and I really need to address, um,
the stupid controversy of the fucking people taking a knee during the national
anthem. You know, watching all these white people getting fucking upset by that.
Like it really does.
It really affects your fucking life and all these fucking idiots trying to make
the point of what they're doing. It's not about your point,
the people who started this thing, it's about my point.
It's about the way that I see it. You know, I had a buddy of mine go, yeah,
he's fucking guys and make $1 million. You know, he think it's bad here.
Why don't you go fucking move to Syria? It's like, why do they have to move?
Why can't they just live here the way you do? I don't understand that and I'm,
but Donald Trump is a fucking genius that he has everybody talking about this
issue because he is trying to get everybody to stop focusing on the pool party
he had with fucking Vladimir. What's his face over there in Russia?
He doesn't want you watching that. He goes, oh look at this over here.
All right.
He goes down to Alabama and he gets all them fucking people all riled up and he
keeps talking about this fatty over in fucking North Korea.
That's what he's still doing. It reminds me of when, Oh fucking slick willy,
you know,
bombed that country cause he stuck his cigar in that woman's Nether region.
This is the type of sick people that become president. This is what they do.
All right? They get caught doing some fucked up shit.
And then I will say this about Trump least he didn't go bomb some people,
unlike what's his face with his bitch hands,
who now gets treated like a fucking hero. I don't understand that guy at all.
You know what I mean? Oh, you go oil's cry. Oh,
I got cocky and my Dick sucked in the older office, so I bombed a country.
I'm outta killed the baby, but I sleep like one ever. Not. Um,
I know I'm a conspiracy theorist. I fucking hate them all.
Did you see that thing? Uh, what's his face in fucking, uh,
Korea considered that we declared war on right. So a,
a Maggie, Megan Hall, whenever fucking name is, uh, Maggie Gyllenhaal.
What is a Ford is the fucking,
the poor woman who has to go out and fucking give the press conferences now
because that dude with no neck, you know,
who kind of looks like the political version of Roger Goodell went out there and
fucked it all up. The hell's her name? She's got a classic political name.
I don't know what the hell it is. She said,
the fact that North Korea thinks that we're at war with them is absolutely
preposterous or something like that. And then like a week before,
what's his face? Trump basically tweeted that,
that that fatty over there wasn't long for this earth.
And it's like you kind of just said he's not going to last.
He's not going to be around long. That's what he said. Yeah.
I mean I would take that as a threat.
All have a dash for his habit dash um, you know what they really need to do?
They both need to just go to a whorehouse together and fucking grow up.
You know, Bang. A couple of whores they need to do a threesome. Right.
One of them is getting blown the others hitting it doggy style and just their
eyes meet and they just start laughing being like, this is a great life. Right.
You've got a personal chef too. That's fucking amazing. You live in a castle,
live in a White House, inmates. Fuck, it's cool. They should just talk about,
you know, trade stories, the way comedians trade stories about bombing.
They could just talk about fucking bomb and other countries and I dunno what
fishing, whatever, whatever people at that level talk about. All right,
let's get to the questions for this week.
So I don't have any fucking problem with these, these guys taking a knee.
I try to listen to what it's about rather than,
than getting wrapped up in what I'm, what, what it means to me. Um,
uh, great pharmacists writing in dear Billy bag chaser.
I Dunno what that meets. Um, by the way, people 39 days sober,
39 fucking days, and this is, this is how well I'm doing with my sobriety. I,
when I flew to Canada, I went by this duty free and this, this uh,
McCallum rare cas, they got this new one black oak or some shit like that.
And I was like, I'm going to buy that. Okay,
I'm not going to take it to fucking Canada then suck it down like a fucking
jackass. I'm just going to have this thing waiting for me. You know what I mean?
For whenever I fall off the wagon.
So this is like what I was thinking the whole ride and like, you know,
I'm getting off the plane,
I'm trying to beat the crowd to get over to the taxi line cause I don't fucking
Uber, I never remembered to set up a car.
So I always go to the fucking taxi line.
And what's great at lax is there's never anybody there cause nobody fucking
takes a taxi if he's got a friend to pick them up. Um,
I don't know what the fuck they do. There's always plenty of cabs.
So I don't even try to be first in line at the cap stand.
I go out of my way over to this duty free place and I grabbed this fucking
thing,
you know, and I like [inaudible]
bring it up to the counter and the lady goes, Oh my God. She goes, fucking, uh,
what a wonderful choice and blah blah, blah, blah, blah. You have great tastes.
I go, I am. I go, I'm on the wagon when I come off,
this is the bottle I'm opening up. She goes, are you going to Canada? I said,
Nope, I'm going home.
And she goes, Oh, I'm sorry I can't sell you this. And I'm like,
why not? She goes, you have to be going to Canada,
some of the about the duty free. And I'm like, it's legal though.
Yeah.
Do they sell this anywhere else in the airport?
If you just going back to your home? They're like, no, no we don't.
So I dunno.
So I had a fucking hissy fit. I had a fucking hissy fit
hi to hissy fits one in the way they're going through Canadian customs.
When they made me take the,
the lime green plastic cover off of my fucking laptop,
like I somehow had a bomb in there or some sort of bomb residue and I'm
literally taking it off going, I'm going to crack this thing. And they go,
well just try to take it off easily.
It's just like, would you look, I look like fucking howdy doody. What? What?
I'm in this matrix. I like what's going on?
Tell me what you want me to do the fuck.
So they make me take that fucking thing off. Ended up cracking the carver.
So I'm already in a bad mood. So, rather than, you know,
growing up and realizing that these fucking people at the,
what is it that the TCA, TCP, whatever, fuck it to Geyer tea, what is it called?
TSA. TSA. The fucking TSA.
Rather than just realizing these people are trying to protect me,
which I don't think they're trying to do.
I think they're trying to make it as inconvenient as fucking possible. So I'll,
I'll agree to have my fucking retina scan so they can share that fucking
information and gradually build a fucking robot.
Sorry, put this fucking headphones back. Um,
yeah, so all I wanted was a bottle of booze. That's all I wanted.
And they wouldn't sell it to me. They wouldn't sell it to me.
So I went online and I'll, I'll figure out a fucking place to get it. All right,
let's, let's do the little right in here. Um,
pharmacist writing in a dear Billy bag chaser.
Your rant on pharmacist last week was hilarious. We have to be able,
able to laugh at ourselves. Right.
I just wanted to weigh in on a couple of things. First off,
the medication you were prescribed,
the antiinflammatory drug you've received was in the nonsteroidal
antiinflammatory drug class. How the fuck do you know?
You didn't even look at it. Maybe you just be, I know,
I can tell just by the way he's talking about it. I understand.
Basically these drugs decrease the formation of prostaglandins and thromb back's
named. Those chemicals are involved in the inflammation process,
which itself causes pain.
So these drugs can't just decrease inflammation without also decreasing pain,
thus being labeled a pain killer. Oh, okay.
Okay.
And ceds are not in the opioid family. Okay.
Are Not happy habit forming. I don't know what this guy's talking about,
but it sounds like he's blowing my argument out of the water. However,
they can be very dangerous in susceptible.
Okay.
Populations. Why can't you say with addicts,
susceptible populations, you guys are such fucking creeps in that world.
And sades n s a I d s and says,
increase the risk of cardiac events, kidney damage and stomach ulcers.
I'm sorry, recovered addicts. Uh,
usually in the elderly or those with preexisting conditions.
I'm not sure what the other drug you receive was.
If it was a narcotic opioid painkiller and the doctrine pharmacist did not
discuss it with you, they would be now negligible on their parts since when?
Since when? I want to know, um, now that the, uh,
the fucking heroin epidemic is completely out of control in the state of Ohio is
suing pharmaceutical companies.
I guarantee I graduated four years ago and the dangers of narcotics was
extremely stressed.
Now all the medical bodies are communicating the dangerous of narcotics to
practitioners and overseeing that prescribing is done appropriately.
And maybe this is just the fucking
okay.
It's just how we are. You know, like when we first,
they first had that DDT and they sprayed it all over the place and this is like
great. We just ended all these plagues and then we did all this damage to the
environment. We created this fucking window that is starting to close,
I feel where it was this golden age of not having to walk around with a fucking
Boyle on your face and dying of the black plague. And, um,
okay.
We just got a little out of control with it,
which would have been great is if as we are radicating all of these different
diseases, if we somehow didn't grow the population,
I feel like that's the sweet spot.
I feel like that's what the fucking Illuminati should be discussing is like what
is the optimal number of people, including ourselves of course,
who should be allowed to survive while we keep all the modern day technologies.
So we can still live this awesome flatscreen life with no plagues.
Okay.
But like we also can still sustain like living on this fucking planet.
What is thing? What is, what is that number?
And they're not taking college cause they're a fucking closed entity. All right,
let me read a few more of these. Wow. How much time are we up to at this point?
18 minutes. 18 minutes plus 37 is 55. Okay. All right,
so here we go. Gold money.com dear Billy copper nuts. Uh,
I heard you talk about gold money.com on your pot Monday morning podcast.
Whoever emailed you about it didn't explain it very well.
I feel like all these are just like free commercials. Um,
I haven't put any money into it yet,
but now I'm going to speak about it as an authority a,
but I am considering it as it seems pretty legit.
If you listen to Rogan's podcast with Peter Schiff,
he explains it pretty well and makes a good pitch. Yeah.
But that guy stands to profit off it.
Granted shift admits that he invested money in the company. Yes. So he's out.
He's out.
I want an independent fucking data.
I can even find that anymore.
Evidently they sell you the gold at a low market price.
Half of 1%, I think.
What do you mean half, half of 1% of what?
That's just sort of a number floating out there, right. Uh,
stored for you in a vault of your choosing with your name on it.
And if you want it, they will actually mail your gold to you for free.
Many of them have like five grams or something.
You also get a mastercard debit card that you can use to spend your gold slash
money. Evidently you can use,
you can even get a debit card that is made of real gold,
which sounds fucking baller. The Federal Reserve and powers that may be,
may never let it work, but it seems like a great idea. At least.
Thanks and go fuck yourself. Yeah, there's a bunch of great ideas. Yeah,
I'm all set on that. Hey, you give me your cash and uh,
we'll put it in gold in a vault that you choose.
That's not where you can see it. Um, all right. Dating and Saudi Arabia.
Now maybe, I dunno, I that sounds like a, even if their,
their mind is in the right place,
it's going to go belly up and then they're all gonna write themselves bonus
checks off your gold. That's what I would guess what happened.
Or the Federal Reserve will come and say this is all legal and take all the gold
and then act like it's in Fort Knox when it's really fucking, uh, I dunno.
I don't know where the fuck it is. Somewhere in the Hamptons. All right.
Dating and Saudi Arabia. Hey there, Billy pie. Billy the pie maker.
Hope you're having a great day. Anyways,
I wanted your advice on this problematic shit that I'm stuck in. I met this guy,
lady
through a common friend of ours. Oh God. We talked and this is nuts,
is going to get messy when you break up with her and you're going to lose her
and a friend a we talked. She's really cool person.
We got a lot of things in common.
Then we met again twice as a friend and now I want to ask her out,
but here's the thing.
She is a Gypson and I'm Indian and we live in Saudi Arabia.
Rabia and dating is illegal here.
Well then what the fuck did you go out with there for now?
Your Heart's going to get cause you to get your fucking, what do they do?
Have that beat your feet in the square.
They're going to fucking slap your dick around in public or something.
Whatever the punishment is over there.
I made the authority could deport you immediately or worse,
send you to jail for years.
Now I really like this girl more than your freedom.
Okay.
All right. Now I really liked this girl and I like you not even love this girl.
And I've already thought of have names for our kids before she even said yes to
me.
But I'm really stuck on thinking through my brain.
Okay, this is second language here. I'm gonna try to help this out here,
but I'm really stuck here.
What she should I think through my brain or through my Dick. Uh, should I?
We'll do none of that is your heart. So you should just leave.
Should I ask her out and open for a whole another level of problems or should I
just shut the fuck up? Any advice to me was highly appreciated.
Loved the podcast and love you as a brother. Go Fuck Yourself.
There's not a woman or a man out there worth going to fucking prison in Saudi
Arabia. I know a bad the prisons are up here.
I don't know what they are like over there. You guys got a lot of oil money. Oh,
I did run into this guy from Saudi Arabia who laughing his ass off and he goes,
dude, we don't, we don't all have oil money. And I was like, all right,
fair enough. This oil man over here, I don't have any of that money. Yeah, dude,
I would walk away from this shit. It's fucking illegal. You could go to jail,
you get deported. You know what I mean? And even if you love somebody,
they're going to annoy the shit out of Eso. I mean,
is that worth going to jail for? You know,
I don't mean is it illegal to just banger, but then if you love her, I dunno.
I Dunno. I would, I would get out of that.
Uh, I get out of it. All right.
All right. Great movie scene. Unknown actor. All right. Oh yeah.
I was talking about, uh, this is the, uh,
this is a new top procure for where I was talking about actors that you saw just
do like five lines in a fucking movie and they absolutely destroyed it.
And you and your friends still quote them.
You don't even know their fucking names. I brought up that guy last week,
the guy from pump a reservoir dogs, the guy in,
you know when Tim Roth's character is a,
what is he? He's in the fucking bathroom and that cops telling that story.
I said, buddy, I am going to shoot you in the face. You know,
put your fucking hands in that dashboard. Love that gun. So here he goes.
One of my favorite scenes with an unknown actor was kill bill to bill's brother
Bud. I wish I need to see these movies to do this justice. I mean, I saw this,
but I don't remember it. Um, she, she wore the same outfit,
that fucking yellow outfit in both movies. Then she,
Bill's brother Bud is working as a bouncer at a rundown strip club.
He shows up late for work, gets called into his boss's office. His boss,
Larry Gomes, is played by actor Larry Bishop,
and he looks like half a wolf man after doing a line of blow with a haggard
looking stripper. I vaguely remember this.
He levels his gaze at buzzed bud and says, uh,
I don't know what car wash you worked before you came here.
They let you stroll in 20 minutes late, but it wasn't owned by you or what?
It wasn't owned by me and I own a fucking car wash.
I just butchered that line. People I can't read.
I've realized that I need glasses and I have slight dyslexia. I'm like,
I was trying to write squawk today and I knew all the letters and I just could
not remember.
So I was trying to remember what squawking 7,700 versus 7,500.
I always get those two mixed up.
If that's an emergency landing or a fucking hijacking,
I was cause one stay alive and the other is fucking go to heaven.
Um, all right, sorry. That's how you remember it. 75 stay alive.
77 and go to heaven. All right, 75 is hijacking.
77 is emergency in 76. Nita fix means you fucking radios out.
This doesn't mean anything to you guys. Um,
I don't know what car wash you worked before you came here and let you stroll in
20 minutes late, but it wasn't owned by me and I own a fucking car wash day.
You go, that was a good fucking read. It makes me want to go see that move.
He say he then proceeded to give this world-class assassin a humiliating dress
down,
telling him he's as useless as an asshole on his elbow and crossing off all his
scheduled work days on the calendar.
He finishes by telling him never to wear his cowboy hat to work and has him
cleaned a clogged toilet on his way out.
All Bud can do is stand there and take it. I hope you've seen this great movie.
If not, it's worth to watch. Thanks and go fuck yourself.
I'm going to go watch it again. All right.
I think I'm a think this bit is going to make people go see these cool movies
again and it's also gonna make everybody laugh at how bad I can't fucking read
out loud. All right, Bill,
my favorite line in a comedy ever might be from blazing saddles delivered by
slim pickins.
He rides into the scene where his workers are singing a camp.
Is it Camptown races?
I always thought it was camp Camptown races and says what the wide wide world of
sport is going on here. I hired you people to try to get,
I had you people to try and get a little track late,
not to jump around like a bunch of kids to city faggots. I remember that line.
Whatever the hell that means. And I'm quoting a movie by the way,
before everybody gets all fucking uptight about the, uh, you know,
Richard Pryor wrote on that and he was actually supposed to be the lead in that.
And then they went with the,
the other actor and I don't know any of the actress names. Okay.
Three number three, Bill.
You asked for movie lines said by a non movie star actress that your listeners
friends talked about from my group of friends. It's aligned from Ghostbusters.
When Peter Venkman, uh,
Bill Murray shows up to Dana's w weaver apartment right after the dog monster
runs loose from Lewis. Tell you I've never seen that movie.
I've never seen Ghostbusters. Just not OSI fi guy.
Vanke is that considered vanquish?
Shows up to the scene and asks a cop what happened.
And the cop nonchalantly replies a some more on brought a cougar to a party and
it went buzzer.
Yeah.
My friends and my been quoting that cop for years.
Check it out at two 30 of the following. Oh, I can, I can look at these. Fuck.
I can click on the links. This is even better.
Why have me read it when I can click on the links. All right.
We'll compare my read.
Come on. No.
Why you lollygagging around here with [inaudible]?
Shoulds seemed like it was 120 degrees. Hey,
be more modern in the fort.
[inaudible] when you a slave,
you saying lie bird gone. How about a good old n****r works, Huh?
Jesus Christ. What the fuck kind of Ligia is sending me here.
I thought that was going to go to your fucking Ah, boy.
Oh boy. Am I going to have to have an apology video here?
What the fuck just happened? Oh, let's do I do this other one. This is,
why are you doing money? You have some of the breeds at room temperature.
If you think it's too warm in here for the Green Luis.
Always yet. All right. All right.
Fuck all these things. These things are going to be too long and evidently they,
they have the n word in them. Yeah. Boy,
do I need to take a knee after this one? All right. Number four.
I have two unknown and unheralded actors with memorable movie lines.
Both are the Great Mel Brooks movies. Uh,
the first one is the Roman soldier in the history of the world, part one,
the empress is approaching, but the, there's a horse and a carriage.
And the way the Roman soldier looks directly at the camera and says,
move that miserable piece of shit. Uh, the over the top way delivers.
The line comes out of nowhere. I say it all the time. And the, uh,
the best impression I could do, you know what I gotta do?
I have to get the actual clips for this to work because what I'm now doing is
ruining, um, ruining great movies. All right. Girlfriend believes in ghosts.
Uh, alright. Girlfriend believes in ghosts dear grandmaster B.
I met this lady a few weeks ago. Things went really good.
She's very cool.
I found her good looking and we have a lot of stuff to talk about.
I didn't have a great a lot of,
I didn't have a lot of relationships in the past.
I'm 32 and I picked up my game about four years ago.
Everything was great until we went to a restaurant one day and she told me she
believes in ghosts,
not just that she said she actually sees them and even got patients who come to
her for treatment about it. I tried to be open minded about it. Oh my God.
I can just hear the silverware hitting the plates at this point,
trying to compare it to people who believe in God,
but her believing in this keeps bugging me. I'm not saying she's crazy or wrong.
Who am I to know? But she doesn't sit right the way I see the world.
Well then fucking dropper. This is the thing.
Now this is whole fucking straight across the board.
You have to look at everything like all the leaves are brown and the sky is
gray. Like if you're dating and somebody does something and it makes you buddy,
you just body literally go like, what the fuck? And then you're literally,
you're going to fight that feeling and go,
well maybe I need to stop being so ghost to phobic. It's like, no,
it's fucking ghosts. It's weird.
You know you're going to fucking live with Whoopi Goldberg's character from
ghosts. That's what you're going to do.
People trying to sit on her and shit trying to sit on your wife.
That's what you're going to sign up for me if that's what you're into,
by all means steward. But if you're on a date and there's like,
that's a major fucking thing. Cause it's not like she just believes in it.
Every once in a while she's going to hear it like a thump in the house and start
telling you it's a ghost. When you're like, honey,
it's fucking air in the pipes. All right,
we just have to fucking turn on the faucet. You know? And you know,
remember if the plumber did work today and they shut it off for a second,
that that's what that is. You know, that's not that she actually,
she's going to become like a ghost hunter and all of that stuff and uh,
gradually she's going to get starts dressing more and more like she can predict
the future and you don't want to fuck that. You know what I mean?
When they start wearing those long flowing things, you know,
you just so many layers of clothes to try and pick up to just get it going.
You know, he start wearing like curtains and shit. You don't need that anyways.
All right. I'm sorry. That whole fucking movie thing just, I dunno,
can you guys just send me the Goddamn clip or I guess you sent me the clip.
What I should've done was cue it up. I tried to do too many things.
I tried to promote shit.
I tried to do all that and then do the whole thing in the whole fucking thing
just fell apart. All right. Let me just finish with this last thing.
A buddy of mine is opening a fucking, uh,
a new comedy club on the upper west side in Manhattan. Okay. Friday,
October six, and October 7th.
It's like a little 100 seat fucking club.
I'm going to be coming to the town in November and I'm going to pop in and do a
spot. I love little clubs like that. Uh, let's see here. Uh,
Russ money's going to be there. Greer Barnes, Mark Norman, John Fish, rod small,
Brian Scott McFadden. Uh, and many more. It's going to be a great show. Uh,
if you're on the upper east side, upper west side, sorry,
it's on a two Oh one west, 75th streets right next to the beacon theater,
which is also cool. You know what I mean?
You go in there and you fucking do your spots and you come out and you go, wow.
Someday I'll be across the street. It's tremendous. Give it a shot.
If you're in town, uh, Friday, October six and October 7th, I got the hiccups.
That's the podcast. Please check out Philippe.
As far as this new stand up special, um, what's it called?
Translate this September 30th on HBO at 10:00 PM.
It's feels more like into gestion. I haven't eaten today. All right.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday.